donc cette semaine on a appris
effectivement que franck reste r donc
remise de la culture avait été testé
positif au corona virus
on a appris ce matin je crois houillères
qui a 16 députés maintenant sur 577 qui
sont touchés également le directeur de
cabinet le direct de valade et kavala
qui obligeait le liger à face à l'équipe
l'apidémie pardon donc faut-il
s'inquiéter pour le couple macro c'est
la question qu'on s'est posée et on
espère avoir la réponse avec vous mon
chat non mais on doit s'arrêter comme
pour n'importe qui mais eux sont quand
même beaucoup plus en contact avec les
gens mais si vous voulez un président et
il va serrer la main de centaines de
personnes dans une journée il peut faire
des bains de foule il est en contact
avec une personnel de l'elysée et ses
dons qu'ils rencontrent et il est à
proximité de beaucoup plus de personnes
que le commun des mortels on n'a vu
l'autre jour quand ils ont été inaugurés
quelque chose sur les champs-elysées ils
sont redescendus après et moi j'ai
remarqué en observant la scène que quand
même la bulle de sécurité avaient changé
c'est à dire que les gardes du corps
sont arrangés pour faire une beaucoup
plus large
d'accord ce qui n'était pas le cas avant
et il s'est pas arrêté pour parler aux
gens pour serrer des mains et servira il
évité bain de foule à l'elysée ils ont
pris des dispositions des dispositions
aussi la salle du conseil des ministres
a été changé pour que ça soit plus
grands et qu'ils puissent espaces et
plus les sièges
maintenant il doit continuer à faire son
métier il doit continuer à montrer que
qu'il est en charge
donc voilà il est obligé de prendre
certains risques mais mesurés
j'ai entendu plusieurs choses par
exemple qui peut pas porter de masse
parce que ce serait un très mauvais
exemple pour les planeurs naskapis de
masques en france d'une il ya une
réquisition de la part de l'état ya plus
de masques si le portait lui épices
enverrait un mauvais message
alors que le ils sont en train de dire
que le max le masque ne sert pas à grand
chose
donc voilà non ça il portera pas de
masse se mettre une est-ce qu'il est
réservé au personnel de santé le masque
un oui et aux malades et la conférence
commis hier par exemple qu'on a vu en
direct ça veut dire que normalement il
ya 10000 attachés de presse des cadreurs
et des machins comment ça se passe et
une allocution comme ça c'est étonnant a
donc ça commence par un non sens on n'a
pas remarqué en direct dans cette
émission c'est des infos
ancré en théorie c'était du direct et
jeux d'outils marie là dessus jusqu'à
tout y est toujours et coûteront pas
dire de bêtises donc je ne sais pas
ouais donc voilà dans dans ces cas-là en
tous les cas ça se passe dans le bureau
oui y'a il ya très peu de monde il ya
les techniciens et voilà c'est s'il n'y
a pas de 10000 attaché de presse et
compagnie ça c'est dans la pièce d'à
côté très bien donc donc de toutes
façons il a pris les mesures barrières
que kick il indique aux gens de prendre
il les prend pour lui aussi alors on a
posé des questions sur notre photo ci
dessous et ils s'inquiétaient pour les
maquereaux nous alors c'est vrai qu'il
est en train il est il est jeune et l'a
40 ans 41 ans de président et fume pas
il boit pas mais je sais pas quand vous
par hasard vous devez les voir par votre
pour votre métier de conseiller de temps
en temps vous ne l'avez dit donc voilà
qu'encore comment ça se passe maintenant
important quand on veut les voir les
mâcon peu à l'elysée on peut dîner on
peut commencer à tourner en parlant de
les toucher on bat là ils évitent de
serrer la main ou embrasser les gens
comme n'importe qui ouais il y en a
marre t you en quoi il est en
amélioration et lui il faut savoir que
les gardes du corps ont des gels
hydroalcooliques bon quand ça lui arrive
de toucher quelque chose c'est rétro les
mains et ce à son bureau et dernier
désinfecter régulièrement et c'est ça il
lui donne du gel et où ils prennent à
elles et les mesures maximum qui postent
moi j'aime bien le genou aussi et je
devrais pas une brigitte mais yo mais tu
sais quoi ça va donner à mon avis des
manières dire bonjour qui vont rester
après le jules à coudre ou une fois les
français vont être propres ont été les
plus craintes d'europe vainqueur
on a une info exclusive au ciné que je
trouve extrêmement intéressant on m'a
dit que l'elysée l'elysée l'elysée a
contacté magali berda magali bernard
dans l'ordre à la m'élisez pour être
celle de mutare est contacté magali
berda justement pour que tu pour qu'on
passe évidemment tout ça de manière
totalement gratuite
je trouve l'initiative si elle est vraie
génial pour passer par les influenceurs
pour ban a évidemment parlé aux jeunes
par matinale pour dire et ont maintenant
des mois et je vais faire pour parler
pour parler aux jeunes des conditions
pour pal le mieux pour toucher les
jeunes c'est de parler aux jeunes est-ce
que ça c'est vrai ou pas être pas
contacté
la papesse mais vraiment c'est plutôt la
vérité c'est que comme tu es influence
ya effectivement on m'a contacté pour
demander aux influenceurs de mon agence
dont toi c'est pour ça que gratuitement
et que tu accepté oui pour juste montrer
les gestes barrières tout simplement sur
leurs réseaux sociaux d'utiliser leurs
réseaux sociaux pour montrer les gestes
barrières et pour aussi mettre le lien
du site du gouvernement pour avoir les
questions réponses est d'accord les gens
se posent des questions d'avoir les
bonnes réponses et pas d'avoir des faits
que news constamment et de pensée pour
ceux qui créent des effets de panique
pour qu'on ait les bonnes réponses à nos
questions
donc juste mettre le lien sur les
réseaux sociaux et dire aux gens voilà
si vous avez des questions allez sur le
lien du gouvernement vous aurez vos
réponses mais c'est quand même un croc
pas synchronisés par par magali bertin
pour communiquer grâce aux courants
navires us magali a pris un mot latin
bois alors un dernier mot pour qu'on
avance
en italie aussi mais les stars se
mobilisent et les influenceurs paraphé
rami qui se mobilisent et qui envoient
des messages quotidiennement à la
population italienne il ya rocco
siffredi aussi quel message très bien
que c'est la coupe nous conduit à
l'époque mois bravo magali ça prouve
quand même que tu es dutil